معنا الان من تلبيب مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري نجوان ارحب بك معضله عسكريه في
اسرائيل يضاف اليها معضله اخرى سياسيه
ايضا تفاصيل كثيره في الواقع كيف يمكن ان
تجمل لنا كل
هذا نعم بالفعل وبخصوص هذه الازمه
السياسيه من الواضح بانها تتفاعل على
مستوى كبير هذا الصباح اعلن او نشر موقع
والله العبري
ان وزراء من حزب المعسكر الرسمي بقياده
الوزير بيني جانس اعلنوا عدم مشاركتهم هذا
اليوم في الجلسه الاسبوعيه
للحكومه وذلك احتجاجا على التهجم الذي حصل
ضد رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي يوم
الخميس الماضي خلال جلسه الكابينه المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
وهذه خطوه تص صعيديه واضحه من قبل بيني
جانز تحديدا الوزير بيني جانز الذي هناك
تطلق دعوات له من تيار واسع في هذا
المعسكر من اجل الانسحاب والاستقاله
من من حكومه الطوارئ التي شكلت بدايه هذه
الحرب لاداره شؤون الحرب بيني جانز كان قد
انضم الى هذه الحكومه رغم انه كان من
احزاب المعارضه فقط بسبب الحرب وهناك
دعوات حاليا له بان ينسحب من هذه الحكومه
كي لا يبقى غطاء كما وصف في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه للاحزاب اليمين المتطرف ولهذا
الهجوم على القياده العسكريه المتمثله
برئيس هيئه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي لكن
هناك ايضا من يدعوه الى التريث في هذه
المرحله والتعبير فقط عن احتجاجه كي لا
يترك المعركه في خضمها وكي لا يترك المجال
ايضا لاقطاب اليمين المتطرف في هذه
الحكومه من تنفيذ اجندته في كل ما يتعلق
بسير العمليات في غزه وبرؤيته ايضا لليوم
التالي في غزه تحديدا قضيه اعاده
الاستيطان وتهجير الالاف او مئات الاف
الفلسطينيين من غزه وهو بطبيعه الحال ما
يعارض الرؤيه الامريكيه للمرحله المقبله
من هذه الحرب قبل قليل في هذا السياق
كان وزير الامن القومي اثمار بن كفير
يتحدث الى الاذاعه العبريه وذكر تحديدا
هذا الموضوع وقال بانه يجب العمل على
تهجير طوعي
للفلسطينيين من من غزه
وبالنظر الى الوضع الذي اصبحت تبدو فيه
غزه بمعنى في اشاره واضحه الى ان كل
عمليات التدمير التي نفذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في داخل غزه كانت تعمده كي لا
يتاح للسكان بالعوده الى هذه المناطق بعد
تدمير المنازل والمباني السكنيه والبنى
التحتيه وكل المؤسسات والمنشات الحيويه
سفيان شكرا لك نجوان سمري من تل